[موسيقى]
يلا يا ولد نزل الشنطه
هلالنا واخيرا القصه التي لا تشبه كل
القصص
[موسيقى]
مرحبا من رمضان الماضي استطعم مسلسل منه
ولدنا انه يصنع لنفسه قاعده جماهيريه
كبيره حيث قدم جيل تلفزيوني جديد من نجوم
الكوميديا الشباب الجزء الجديد جاء من
زاويه مختلفه فبعد ما كانت القصه تدور فقط
في جزء الاول عن الشابين اتبدلوا وقت
الولاده وما ترتب على ذلك
ركز الجزء الجديد على امور اخرى كطموحات
كل منهما وكيف دمرت احداهما الاخرى
بيكون في شيء اصعب يعني او انه لازم احنا
نصير احسن او هم يصيرون احسن انا احس كل
فريق او كل عمل له جوا وكل ناس او يعني كل
ناس لهم لهم الاشياء اللي يحبونها
يعني اتجه الى منحنى مختلف تماما عن الجزء
الاول وبيكون واضح بالنسبه للمشاهد الجزء
الاول ممكن كان التركيز اكثر شيء على
الكوميديا بينما الجزء الثاني لا تفرع
وراح اتجاه النصر الى عده امور ولكن ما
تخلو من الكوميديه الكوميديه موجوده ولكن
المستوى الدرامي اصبح اكثر من الكوميديا
ولكن بطريقه لطيفه وخفيفه على المشاهده
المسلسل تصنيفات شاهد استطاع انه يحترم
مركز الرابع في السعوديه من ناحيه ارقام
المشاهده اسهم في ذلك بحسب راي النقاط
توقيت عرضه مباشره بعد مسلسل طاش في
الفتره الذهبيه نجاح الموسم الاول
حملنا مسؤوليه كبيره كان نجاح كبير وعظيم
والحمد لله رب العالمين يعني
وصلنا فيه لمناطق كنا حابينه وصلنا لها
فالجزء هذا احنا في مسؤوليه علينا لازم
نكون نقدم افضل
من الجزء الاول فالجزء الثاني في مفاجات
حلوه في احداث جميله في تنوع شخصيات تنوع
احداث جميله بصراحه عائله وحده ولا الشارع
قاعد نقدمها جدا جميل الحمد لله تغير
الكركتر بيني كريان وبين الاستاذ عند محمد
كان جميل جدا ليش للريان الموسم الاول كان
قاسي معها تماما الين صار الدرس اللي هو
رجع العالم الفقر ثم رجع لمكانه حقيقي
مع بعض التغريدات من هنا وهناك
[موسيقى]
احنا حبيناك عشانك انت
انا حبيتك عشانك انت فلا تغير نفسك عشاني
[موسيقى]
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات